all right well let's get the view now
from the labor party I'm pleased to say
we're joined by the shadow Justice
secretary Steve Reed Steve Reed good
morning to you nice to meet you this
morning so listen you will have seen
some of the reporting in the papers this
morning that the um the incoming prime
minister is going to have if it's list
for us a 100 billion pound package to
try and help people deal with their
energy bills and it might involve a
price cap you must be happy with that
well it's the only the only source of an
actual plan that we've heard so far is
the labor party's fully costed plan to
freeze Energy prices so that we can
spare families from the eye watering
terrifying five or five and a half
thousand pound increases in bills that
are now anticipated by next April
despite the fact that Liz truss and
Rishi sunak have been fighting each
other like rats in a sack all the way
through the summer neither of them has
come up with a plan to deal with the
energy crisis even though one of them
will be announced as the new Tory leader
today and one of them will walk into
Downing Street tomorrow neither of them
has told us what they would do it's only
labor that has come up with a plan to
freeze energy bills and they could do a
lot worse than having ruled out helping
families Liz trust said she wouldn't be
helping families because that was what
labor did but having having performed so
many u-turns this year already on issues
like the the windfall tax which we
proposed they rejected and then they
picked up they could do a lot worse than
picking up our plan to freeze energy
bills now because Millie millions of
families up and down this country need
that help so it does sound like you do
support the idea of making sure that
there is enough money spent to try and
help those who most need it this winter
well it's critical that we help families
first of all because we cannot be in a
situation where we allow 10 million
families through no fault of their own
to fall into debt or into destitution I
mean genuinely it staggers me that
neither of the katori leadership
contenders have come up with any plan at
all kierstama came up with one weeks ago
but if they don't do that if Liz trusts
let's say she wins and refuses to help
which is what she originally threatens
to do and you push families into debt in
that way what happens to the economy
that's potentially 10 million families
that don't go out to the shops don't go
to restaurants don't go to bars you
freeze up the economy and we already
have got thanks to you know these two
both were in the cabinet that caused
this we've got the lowest level of
growth of any of the 20 major economies
in the world apart from Russia which is
subject to Major sanctions if they push
us even further behind that will have a
devastating effect on many many more
people up and down countries so they
need to pick up Labor's fully costed
plan and implemented it implement it
because we cannot allow families to see
their energy bills rise to three and a
half thousand pounds in October four
thousand pounds by January and five or
six thousand pounds by April and that is
what the forecast say will happen
yes as we've discussed before this only
costed for six months and we've we have
talked about what will happen in the
next six months and you never got an
idea for that so we'll leave that where
that is for now uh I want to talk to you
about your brief as Shadow Justice
secretary we've got a barrister strike
and all out strike beginning this week I
mean will the labor party do to try and
stop barristers from walking out of
court and uh jamming up the justice
system well first of all the the
criminal justice system is already
broken Liz truss of course used to be
the Justice secretary and when she was
Justice secretary she reduced the number
of judges and sold off the courts
contributing to what became the biggest
backlog of cases uh in our country's
history even before the pandemic hits
there were now sixty thousand cases
waiting waiting in the courts to be
heard for a rape case now you wait three
years uh to cart to come to trial and
that's if you're one of the one and a
half percent of reported rapes that ever
gets to trial in the first place so the
criminal justice system is absolutely
broken because of what the government's
done now nobody wants to see a strike
making that even even worse barristers
you know with their gowns and their wigs
and not a naturally militant group of
people they've never gone on strike
before but they're striking because of
the disarray and the Justice uh in the
in the criminal justice system and
frankly because the government went back
on the commitments they made to properly
fund uh properly fund legal aid a piece
of work that they commissioned and that
was written by a conservative a
conservative peer now what Dominique
robber whoever becomes Justice secretary
secretary could do is sit down with a
Criminal Bar Association that represents
barristers and try to talk through the
problems they've said on each occasion
this year when they've held a ballot on
Industrial action they've said if
Dominic Rob will the Justice secretary
sat down and spoke with them they would
call off the action if I was the Justice
secretary that is what I would do
frankly we have a zombie government in
so many respects but one way that they
can help with these strikes is simply to
talk to the uh to the barristers and
perhaps try to keep their word on the
legal aid funding program which they
first of all said in the House of
Commons they would support but then went
back on okay and finally then Steve I
mean if the reporting is correct and it
seems to be pretty accurate and this
trust does win the leadership racing
comes our next prime minister uh who she
suggested to be in her cabinet looks
like being one of the most diverse
cabinets in history and of course it
will be the conservative party's third
prime minister the labor party haven't
even had a female leader you must be a
little bit jealous of the way that the
conservative party seems to have a
diverse top team in place well Kamali we
we don't actually know who's won yet let
alone who would be
um in their cabinets so that's so that's
a that's a bit of speculation but I'll
tell you what really matters what really
matters to the British people is what
they do not what they are and right now
the biggest crisis facing our country is
the is the escalating energy bills
Labor's got a fully costed plan soon I
can trust have both said nothing about
what they would do the country needs
help now that requires a real fresh
start which neither of these two can
give only a labor Government Can can
deliver that